in this series I'm going to surprise you
I'm going to strip away all the
complexity and hard graft and teach you
how to cook amazing food standing on
your head that is amazing incredibly
tender from the kitchen novice to the
budding Chef I'm going to give you the
confidence the recipes and the inside of
knowledge to make you a much better cook
slice around wasting
[Music]
nothing I made my name cooking in some
of the world's most demanding kitchens
it's nice make service yeah in my
restaurants I expect Perfection every
plate has to be worthy of a Michelin
star and every time you make it taste it
as well every day changes here now I'm
going to show you some simple and
accessible recipes for fantastic food
that you can easily cook at
home incredible I'll be holding you by
the hand just getting better and better
and better teaching you everything from
incredible stressfree dishes real fast
food and my ultimate feast recipes this
is the only cookery course you'll ever
need
Welcome to My ultimate cookery course
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stay your life on right
this is my ultimate food on a
budget as a chef I know it's not what
you spend on ingredients but results on
the plate that
count using cheap cuts and leftovers and
working them hard in the kitchen gives
you food and a budget that tastes a
million bucks and I'm going to show you
how first up my flavor packed Lamb with
fried bread whether I'm cooking high-end
dishes or rustic dishes trust me it all
has to be impressive so this lamb dish
proves that you don't have to spend a
fortune to create delicious
food first off put the pan
on this is a lamb steak and it's cut
just above the leg just here cuz you can
see that delicious bone running through
the center and that's full of marrow so
that just gives the lamb a nice Added
Sweet flavor
just take your knife cut through each
end this stops the lamb steak from
buckling so therefore it Cooks evenly
and colors beautifully salt and
pepper lamb needs quite a lot of help
with the pepper so be quite generous
with the pepper and just Pat that down
the pan just starting to smoke on the
outside now put the oil in get that pan
really nice and hot because this is a
cheap cut so I'm depending on the color
of the lamp steak to really sort of part
a lot of flavor that's the noise you
want to hear if you can't hear that
noise don't drop the steak in put a
little bit of garlic in there not Chop
garlic just whole close the garlic
lightly
crushed don't even waste time peeling
them in tongs lift up that bit of fat
around the back that's the top of the
leg tilt the pan and let all that fat
render rendering is a chef's term that
means melting the fat it works
brilliantly when you you're cooking a
ribe eye as well turn it
over that color there
beautiful now it looks like an expensive
cut and we got that nice even sear all
over as it's cooking just tilt the pan
and
bakee and basing the lamb Stak just
means you're sort of adding all that
nice scented garlic olive oil back into
the lamb
useful now take the lamb out and let the
lamb rest
[Music]
one now for the perfect rustic Crouton
so this Bread's quite firm couple of
days old just slice it straight down the
[Music]
center dice it up put it into a
bowl season it
beautifully from there I'm add some milk
sounds strange adding milk to Crouton
but it just gives it that nice rich
creamy texture and just let that milk
sort of absorb into the bread while
that's soaking I'm going to make the
dressing go back to that initial garlic
that was in the pan look at that
beautiful into the pest and water and
chv an chies go brilliantly well with
lamb I want that nice salty vinegary
flavor and a bit of kick some Capers the
little baby caps very sweet
now just pound that to a nice
paste that smells incredible next some
deel mustard a nice teaspoon and a half
in a little bit of red wine vinegar 2
tablespoons and then our extra ver in
olive oil
now it's got that heat in there got that
nice roasted garlic a real hearty chunky
vinegarette that sort of seeps into that
lamb some fresh
parsley crunch up the parsley delicious
flavor parsley
in
nice now get your pan hot for the
croutons olive oil in the
pan grab the croutons and squeeze all
that excess milk out not too hard I
don't want them dry and
in and then just fry them and the milk
inside these croutons give it a nice spy
creamy delicious
flavor that's the color I want nice now
take them out and lightly drain them
little bit of kitchen roll onto the
board
[Music]
out plate them just take this amazing
vinegarette and spread it get those
croutons listen to them like little
Boulders hitting the plate the lamb sit
that on next
one on rest of the
croutons on I use all those little bits
and my chef in Paris would kill me right
now if you saw me using those because
they're the ugly scraps that customers
should never see but but they're the
best bits croutons on and then just drop
that sauce on those little
bits of the
lamb and there that is a perfect way of
taking a cheap cut into the Premier
League of
dishes stunning food doesn't have to be
complicated keeping it simple produces
amazing results and keeps cost down here
are three more great easy dishes that
don't cost the Earth but taste
absolutely
incredible starting with roasted
mackerel with garlic and
[Music]
paprika first make a spicy paste by
crushing garlic and a pestel and mortar
along with Paprika sea salt and olive
oil spoon the paste onto filets with
mackerel a great inexpensive oily fish
that's really healthy and leave to
marinade when ready to eat put the
mackerel fets on a baking tray skin Side
Up season and roast in a hot
oven next make a Tangy potato salad for
the dressing mixed dejon mustard white
wine
vinegar olive oil and
saffron and whisk until
blended boil new potatoes in salted
water drain and lightly
Crush add sliced spring onion and Spoon
in the
[Applause]
vinegarette to serve top the potato
salad with the roasted mackerel and
drizzle with more vinegar
[Music]
ET a healthy meal that makes the most of
cheap but delicious fish stunning
roasted mackerel with garlic and
[Applause]
[Music]
paprika my next brilliant budget
dish is pork and PRN balls in aromatic
[Music]
broth for the pork and porn balls in a
bowl add pork
mins then add finally chopped
[Music]
prawns diced
Ginger and chopped
[Music]
chives
seasoned and roll into pingpong siiz
[Music]
balls for the broth peat fresh
stock and add stares oyster sauce soy
sauce and sliced
Ginger
gently
simmer fry the pork and praw ballls in a
pan until
golden then transfer to the bubbling
broth add handfuls of spinach then serve
top with finely sliced spring onions a
gorgeous healthy dish that uses Great
Value ingredients with amazing results
pork and prawn balls in aromatic broth
ready to eat in under 20
minutes
an incredibly simple recipe that's
perfect for using up leftovers easy
arini delicious golden rice
[Music]
balls first chop mozzarella into small
cubes then take handfuls of leftover
risotto add a cube of mozzarella and
fold into a bow around the
cheese this dish is perfect with
leftover mushroom Roto but it's great
with any risoto for the coating prep
three bowls one with flour one with
breadcrumbs and one with beaten egg dip
each arini first into the flour then the
egg wash and finally the
breadcrumbs then in a pan heat the olive
oil and Fry the arini into golden
brown drain and serve simply with
lemon easy aini a delicious tempting
treat that's great for leftovers and
Cooks in under 10
minutes three quick and easy recipes
that give maximum flavor for minimum
cost fantastic dishes that prove you
don't have to spend a fortune to eat
amazing food at home
nice next five more of my 100 tips
that'll make cooking in the kitchen
easier first up a great cheap staple how
to cook the perfect rice basmati rice
the king of all Rices light fluffy
delicious and I'm I'm going to show you
how to cook it
perfectly now start off with 400 G of
rice rice in spot on so what I'm going
to do now is just rinse off the dust and
the star cold water
always and just rinse the rice that
stops the rice from becoming clumpy in
the pan and allows it to become really
nice light and fluffy once it's cooked
rice
into the pan now to make a plain fluffy
rice exciting we're going to infuse it
three cardamon pods and just get the
pods and just Pierce them so it allows
all that flavor to come out cardamon
pods and then staranise now these are
beautiful whole
staranise it makes it really nice and
fragrant salt and pepper a lot easier to
season the rice now than it is is once
it's cooked you start to break it up
when you season it once it's cooked now
basically one part rice to 1 and 1/2
part water 600 Ms always start off in
cold water cold water
in onto the gas lid on bring it up to
the Bowl as quick as possible and turn
it down and let it simmer for 8 to 10
minutes and that's the secret behind
cooking great rice allow it to steam as
it's cooking do not lift that lid up
lid
off M it smells aromatic basically all
the water's absorbed the rice has
doubled in size and it's nice and light
and fluffy take the Starnes out the
cardan pods they all should have risen
to the top pods out take your fork fluff
it through basically it just sort of
starts to open everything back
up once you forked it through becomes
really nice nice and light and fluffy
and uh that is perfectly cooked
rice always make the most of your
leftovers use last night's rice in stir
fries scrambled up with eggs or it's
simple to make a delicious Fresh Salad
remember a good cook waste
nothing a great tip for stopping
potatoes apples and avocados from going
brown when cut simply cover with water
and add a squeeze of lemon the acidity
stops the flesh from oxidizing which is
what causes the C to
change herbs are great for adding flavor
without spending a fortune to keep them
at their best simply place them in a
glass of water and they'll stay fresh
for up to a
[Music]
week and if you've got extra herbs left
over save and waste by making an amazing
flavor to oil place wash and dried stems
in a bottle cover with warmed olive oil
then seal and leave to infuse great for
salads pastas and drizzling on veg
coming up on my Ultimate Guide to
cooking on a budget how to make the most
of your ingredients this is where you
get so much more bang for your buk out
the sausages because the Skin's off and
the real flavor is going to come through
more essential kitchen knowledge you
should be cut in like this there's more
flavor and a delicious and cheap spicy
sausage rice that is an amazing way to
take spicy Italian sausages to a
completely different
level this is my ultimate cookery course
100 recipes to take your life on later
I'll be showing you an incredible spicy
sausage rice that cost next to nothing
bulky delicious and Incredibly robust
but first when you're cooking on a
budget you can still eat fantastic Meats
just make sure you're getting the most
for your money next up my shopping guide
to buy the best hams salamis and
sausages These Fine Italian meats are
packed with flavor and a little goes a
long way and no nobody knows that better
than Delhi Maestro Antonio sakani I born
in Italy and I start eating Italian food
and I love it I want to change it for
nothing else that's why I'm
fat he's been selling delicious cured
meats in the heart of London Soho for
more than 35 years this is the best
pruto they come from Italy this is Cur
in Palma because it's Palma h
Divine people love it and it's wonderful
the fat is good because you make the
meat sweet they should be cut th like
this there's more flavor you can eat
with melon with figs with pears with
everything any sweet fruit is
good it's wonderful you really enjoy
when you start eating you can stop
wonderful this is called braaa it's a
hair cured beef come from a North Italy
valina is so different from pork it's no
fat at all it should be no fat thewi it
tastes greasy it's good when it's very
dry and you slice it thin up you just
eat it like that or you can eat put a
bit of Rocket I shave some Parmesan on
top I love it bit of lemon if you like
or olive oil it's
delicious this is called Felino for me
it's is the best salami take the name
for a little place near farma and there
is country salami very nice it's one of
my favorite because it's not too spicy
just meat flavor just salt and pepper I
love it I can't
resist when I take some meat home I
don't need nothing else especially in
the evening just meat with a melon or
fish or whatever
few slices of bread couple glasses of
wine that's my meal you don't need
nothing else you know
you you
happy Antonio is Right incredible
Italian hams and salamis are fantastic
in simple salads sandwiches or even
eaten by themselves and you don't need
much to make an
impression there's an amazing selection
of delicious Meats from around the world
that are great to use in the kitchen
another simple meat staple that's
perfect for quick easy suppers with a
difference are the Exotic Regional
speciality sausages that have such
distinctive tastes and are a million
miles from the Great British Banger here
are four of my favorites that are
definitely worth your money Chito from
Spain these have an incredibly deep red
color are full of smoky spice paika and
are great for stuffings stews and pellas
merges from North Africa made from beef
or mutton these cook super fast because
of their long and thin shape and can be
used in tajines or served with cuscus
fennel sausages from Italy made from
pork and packed with sweet aned flavor
fennel seeds these are perfect with
pasta or as a topping on a pizza finally
jerk sausages from Jamaica full of blow
your head off Scotch bonnet chilies
these are super spicy and great in Tangy
casseroles or simply sauteed with onions
and garlic be adventurous with your
sausages learn about the different
flavors and you'll soon be using them to
add extra flavor with
ease
for dishes that always pack a punch
without costing a fortune simple and
cheap delicious ingredients like
sausages are great and you don't need a
lot of them to get stunning dishes that
taste incredible so spend your money
wisely and you can have amazing midweek
meals that don't cost the Earth my next
recipe is all about great flavors and
it's as cheap and easy to make as it is
delicious spicy sausage rice whatever
you're cooking the secret of making
great food is to ensure you lock in
every last ounce of flavor in that pan
and this spicy sausage rice does exactly
[Music]
that take these spicy sausages and
Pierce that skin cuz I want all that
delicious spicy sausage meat out of its
casing and you get more flavor from the
sausage when you take them out the
casing sausage is ready turn on the gas
bread onion less acidic than a big white
Spanish onion and a lot more
flavorsome tablespoon of olive oil a
tablespoon only because I want all that
fat coming out of the sausages to sort
of really help flavor the onions onions
in and the onions go in first because
you can never Rush cooking an onion it's
really important to sort of give them
five to 6 minutes in the pan so you can
really start to caramelize them and now
put my pepper slice around wasting
nothing I want to see that sort of
little core those Pips in the center no
fine DIC pepper the rice is going to be
cooking for 20 minutes so I want the veg
to sort of have texture after it's
cooked Pepper's in a bit of garlic two
nice
cloves just slap
down off with the
shell garlic
in now we turn up the gas get the pan
nice and hot because the minute that
sausage goes in everything cools down
and you'll end up boiling the peppers
and the onions and the garlic so heat up
to maximum and then just make a well in
the
center
in now start stirring quickly and this
is where you get so much more bang for
your bu out the sausages because the
skins off and the real flavor of that
spicy Italian sausage is going to come
through what's great great about this
recipe is that you can use any type of
sausage to get the flavor and the heat
you want I've gone for the spicy Italian
but it's just as good with MES or eat
so a teaspoon Paprika in give it that
really nice Smoky
flavor rice in and we're going to sort
of basically sear the rice we call it in
the kitchen blasting the rice where we
sort of s to the rice for 30 seconds and
it takes on all that
flavor next
white
wine so the wine sort of Del glazes the
pan and washes all that flavor from the
bottom of the pan into the rice stock in
bring it up to the boil turn it down and
let it
simmer m double stop to Rice turn that
gas down and let it simmer 12 to 15
minutes and just give it the occasional
stir keep an eye on it now get ready to
finish
it slice spring onions dice sweet juicy
tomatoes and roughly chop earthy flat
leaf
parsley spring ons in tomatoes in off
with the gas really important otherwise
everything becomes overcooked flat leaf
parsley in but look at the volume in
that pan now that is an amazing way to
take spicy Italian sausages to a
completely different level
[Music]
beautiful
Follow My ultimate cookery course packed
with key
lessons top tips and 100 recipes to
stake your life on and you'll literally
be cooking yourself into a better Chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details go on get
cooking in this series I'm going to
surprise you I'm going to strip away all
the complexity and hardcraft and teach
you how to cook amazing food standing on
your head that is amazing incredibly
tender from the kitchen novice to the
buding chef I'm going to give you the
confidence the recipes and the inside of
knowledge to make you a much better cook
slice around wasting
[Music]
nothing I made my name cooking in some
of the world's most demanding kitchens
it's nice you make service yeah in my
restaurant I expect Perfection every
plate has to be worthy of a Michelin
star and every time you make that as
well every day it changes now I'm going
to show you some simple and accessible
recipes for fantastic food that you can
easily cook at
home incredible I'll be holding you by
the hand just getting better and better
and better teaching you everything from
incredible stressfree dishes real fast
food and my ultimate feast recipes this
is the only cookery course you'll ever
[Music]
need Welcome to My ultimate cookery
course packed with cooking tips
information and 100 recipes to stay your
life on right this is more ultimate food
on a
budget vegetables are such an asset in
the kitchen healthy fantastically fresh
and Incredibly versatile and
pound-for-pound they're so much cheaper
than fish or meat just make sure you
give them plenty of
attitude my first recipe is so quick and
easy but seriously impressive and
deceptively
cheap homemade noi making your own noi
is so simple to do yet the results are
absolutely stunning and it's a great way
of using up leftover baked
potatoes you can make Noy just with
flour and eggs however the potato gives
it that nice light sort of creamy fluffy
texture let's cut them in half take your
spoon and scoop the inside of those
potatoes I'm using leftover baked
potatoes but this really works as well
with leftover bow potatoes two choices
you can get a fork and sort of mash the
potato and get it nice and light and
fluffy or this little Gadget it's called
a riser I suppose it's a posh word for a
potato masher just squeeze gently you
can see how nice and light it is almost
like fluffy little strands of potato you
can do this when the potatoes are hot
it'll go through the rice so much
quicker just slice that off
there now a nice spoon of aotter in
little touch of salt and pepper it's
really important to season the mixture
as we go along otherwise The Noy becomes
really Bland flour over the ricotta
saved so there's no
lumps one delicious egg give that little
whisk now make a little well in the
center you want a nice soft pliable ball
of dough give that a really good
mix get some th flowers in there and
this time is light fragrant it's just a
really nice herb and with the ricotta it
tastes brilliant just pick the little
tips the th
flowers next flour your hands generously
and knead the mixture into a
dough fold in and push and basically
what it's doing is get it nice and
smooth as it starts to get a little bit
wet and just add a little touch or flour
but we want something really nice and
soft now don't overwork it just stops
The Noy from expanding when it hits the
pan that's exactly what I want a nice
sort of soft fragrant ball cut the ball
in half lightly
flour the hands and just roll it gently
and just think of a a big long cigar the
mixture will start getting a little bit
sort of wetter but do not add lots of
flour now lightly flatter the knife so
when you slice The Noy it doesn't
stick cut the dough into bite-sized
pieces just take your finger dip it in
the flow and push down why I want my Noy
to look like a pillow and for me the
most important part there is that not
one of them are identically the same
shape water
on bring it up to the boil little touch
of olive oil in there lightly flower
your
hand lift up the
Noy into the rolling boiling
water turn that pan to stop them and
sticking at the bottom and let them
simmer and they start to sort of tell
you they're cooked when they start
floating get a pan on get that nice and
hot now they're just starting to come up
to the top and you can continue cooking
them like that I like blanching them in
the water taking them out and then
frying them to S The Noy heat olive oil
in a frying pan gently lift up and look
they've doubled in size drain it get rid
of the excess water and straight in the
hot
pan
[Music]
this is where they start to take on a
completely different texture nice crisp
so texture on the outside Noy loves
fresh pepper
so pepper
[Music]
in and you'll see as I start turning
them got this really nice little sort of
brown color and they're almost puffing
up now like little Parcels so I want the
nice some saes both sides but light and
creamy in the
center Fresh Garden peas in and the
butter gives it that really nice sort of
BU noisette flavor on the
end beautiful put a little bit of fresh
thyme over the peas and then finally I
want to lift it up fresh lemon zest the
lemon
[Music]
over so smells and
incredible and then finally seal the
deal with a touch of gry palms and
cheese give you veg some attitude and
you'll get amazingly elegant dishes on a
budget that are always guaranteed to
impress what more do you want from great
cooking C to make easy to cook and
absolutely
stunning cooking grap food doesn't mean
you have to spend a fortune on fancy
equipment get some Basic Essentials and
you'll be set in the kitchen sauce pants
I mean basically you don't need a
collection of 10 all you need really is
two a mediumsized one followed by a
large one a small pan is great for
sources heating liquids or rice whereas
your large pan gives you space perfect
for pastas stews or when you're cooking
in bulk which keeps cost down made from
copper to stainless steel find what's
right for you and always get a lid which
helps heat the pan up as quickly as
possible and the secret behind a great
saucepan is the heavier the bottom the
more heat it will conduct the thinner
the bottom the more chance you've got
actually burning with food buy the best
sauce bus you can afford take good care
of them and they'll last you years
saving you money in the long
[Music]
[Applause]
run amazing recipes don't necessarily
have to include meat cooking vegetarian
dishes will reduce your food bills
without compromising on taste and flavor
here are three more recipes to satisfy
even the keenest carnivore like me that
will max out on veg and won't break the
bank
starting with spicy black beans with
feta and
[Music]
[Applause]
avocado first in a pan heat olive oil
add chopped onion and Fry until
soft then finally slice
garlic and
chili add
cumin cinnamon and black beans then
combine cook together until deliciously
soft these small beans come dry or in
tins and are a great cheap ingredient to
make dishes more substantial to serve
dollop the black bean mixture on crunchy
tortillas top with Cube ripe avocado
chopped fresh coriander and crumbled
salty Fetter
cheese spicy black beans with feta and
avocado a dish has filling Fugal and
tastes
fantastic my next great veg recipe is
leak and GRE Rusty with fried
[Music]
eggs in a hot pan sweat shredded leaks
along with a knob of butter and
[Music]
season next great pbed potatoes and
Grier a hard swiss cheese with a great
nutty
flavor then combine with the soften
leaves in a pan heat oil and a little
butter spoon in the potato leak and
cheese mix cook gently until golden and
crisp underneath then slide onto a
plate flip over and return to the pan to
finish
cooking finally for the perfect topping
fry two eggs and place them on top of
the
rosty top with fresh
taragan leaking gria rosty with fried
eggs a simple but substantial dish that
makes the most of hearty root
veg a dish that takes as much time to
write on a Blackboard as it does to cook
chickpea cumin and spinach cofs with
tahini
dressing in a blender put tin chickpeas
cumin seeds paprika and turmeric and
Blitz to a
[Music]
paste next wi spinach in olive oil and
chop finely then add to the chickpea
mixture sprinkle in gram flour made from
finely ground chickpeas then shape golf
ball side chunks of the mixture using a
spoon and rest in the fridge when ready
to cook heat oil in a frying
pan shallow fry the cofas until golden
brown on all sides then rest them on
kitchen paper to absorb any excess
oil for an easy dipping sauce Mix Yogurt
with a dollop of
tahini and a squeeze of lemon then stir
in freshly chopped
coriander a mouthwatering dish that's
perfect for sharing chickpea cumin and
spinach cofas with tahini
dressing three amazing recipes with
fantastic veg proof that even if you're
cooking on a budget you can still eat
like a king incredible coming up I'm my
Ultimate Guide to cooking on a bud
have to get the most from your
ingredients there's a lot of flavor in
the skin so don't worry about peeling
the fruit all about shopping for perfect
potatoes cook them simply proper flavors
it doesn't get any better and a
delicious apple dish to stake your life
on look at it a delicious but very
simple crumble
beautiful welcome back to my ultimate
cookery
course this is how to cook amazing food
on a
budget next up my guide to getting the
best ingredients for your money my
shopping Mantra is simple first rely on
your senses make sure whatever you're
buying that it looks smells and really
feels good second is to recognize that
knowledge is crucial the more you know
personally about where your ingredients
are from and how they produce the better
so don't be scared ask lots of questions
and
learn and when it comes to buying
potatoes a great ingredient if you're
cooking on a budget one green grosser
who can always spot a dud bud is bur
Market royalty Fred Foster it's all
about Flavor it's all about choosing the
right variety for the right fish he's
been selling top quality veg for over 15
years and really knows his King Edwards
from his Duke of Yorks basically there's
two types of potatoes there's early
season and a main crop potato early
season is basically round about May time
you can't store them they cannot be
stored you have to buy them and use them
within 2 to 3 days when you're buying an
early season potato you must avoid green
looking potatoes at all costs it really
is important and the way you can tell
that is if you just brush the potato the
skin comes off really really easy and
then you want you want a yellowy or
Whitey looking potato the new season
potato is a superb potato to use new
season types include rocket homeg guard
and Maris B but my favorite is the
classic jersey Royal it has a delicate
sweet flavor it's packed with vitamin C
and and is great in salads or simply
boiled and mixed with olive oil and
fresh mint Jersey potatoes early crop
are phenomenal look at that
um keep the skin on it's really
important just wash it boil it it's a
beautiful beautiful potato and and
that's what we're talking about we're
talking about I know it's a potato I
know it's a bit sad but we're talking
about
Flavor right and what is a main crop
potato it's the crop that is grown
specifically
for 9 months of a year use when you're
looking at a main cro potato you need to
see that the the eyes aren't too large
because they tend to go right through
the potato they've got to be firm it's
very very important if a potato in any
way feels a little bit soft discard it
storage wise dark place cool place dry
place and that will last till you eat it
simple as that both early season and
main crop potatoes come in two main
types waxi and and flowy waxy potatoes
have a smooth dense flesh and because
they're low in starch they stay firm
when
cooked types include Ana and pink fur
but I love Charlotte which has an
amazing buttery taste and are great soed
in stews or serves whole with roast
chicken flowy potatoes have a fluffy dry
texture when cooked which makes them
great for mashing roasting or cutting
into chips types include King Edward
whose smooth creamy flesh is perfect for
potato Gratton or with Rich meat like
beef and desire which have an amazing
red skin and are great for baking or as
delicious potato wedges oldfashioned
types known as Heritage potatoes are now
widely available and have fantastic
colors and distinctive tastes that are
great when you want something different
this one's called Salad blue when you
cut it you then see the most amazing
color and it's perfect it looks stunning
on the plate are really popular it's so
important when you're going out to pick
your potatoes you already know in
advance what you're going to do with
that potato so whether you're going to
put it in a salad whether it's a Masher
or a chipper or even a baking potato
each variety has a unique flavor Fred
spot on whether new season main crop
waxi or flowy potatoes are incredibly
versatile and packed with great flavor
the perfect ingredient when you're
cooking on a budget well how much do I
love potatoes well cook them simply
proper flavors it doesn't get any better
right
like all chefs for me there's nothing
better than seasonal produce at its peak
when fruit and vegg is fresh in seasoned
and fantastically ripe I can't wait to
get back in the
kitchen to get the most out of your
cooking always use ingredients in their
Prime my next recipe is a proper British
classic that's super simple to cook and
cost next to nothing a delicious apple
crumble crumbles are the perfect way to
use fruit when it's in season there's
lots of it about it's nice and cheap but
most importantly the fruit is at its
absolute
best first off I'm going to make a
really nice light caramel pan on nice
and low great two
[Music]
apples this helps to almost sort of pure
the Apple so much quicker there's a lot
of flavor in the skin so don't worry
about peeling the fruit whether it's
pears plums peaches flavors in the
skin nice to start the caramel a couple
of tablespoons of sugar the sugar helps
to get rid of the tartness in the Apple
a touch of cinnamon that starts to make
it a little spicy open up your vanilla
just scrape out all those seeds now this
just makes it light and fragrant all
those seeds in to the sugar when making
caramel be patient and and always SWR
the dish instead of stirring it when the
sugar goes Brown add the
Apple that starts to sort of cool down
the caramel but it gives it a really
nice sort of caramelized puray Apple's
almost
disintegrating smells incredible turn
the gas down slice up two apples it's a
crumble that's got no FRS
straightforward no faffing around no
paning of the skin I want them to sort
of stand out from the caramel apples
in now those nice thick chunks of Apple
is sort of almost beding itself into the
puree dried cranberries gives it that
nice sort of shock in the texture sweet
and chewy I want it to sort of taste
zesty spicy so sit the lemon zest on top
of your apples and
cranberry fresh lemon juice over and
that just gives that extra acidic kick
takes the Cranberries the apples the
caramel and the cinnamon to another
level turn the gas off just let that sit
let's concentrate on the crumble flour
in a couple of tablespoons of Demar
sugar sugar helps to get the topping
nice and crispy butter in give that a
nice little sort of rub what we're
looking for is like a a breadcrumb
mixture lightly season it with a touch
of cinnamon
and the Demar sugar sort of helps to get
a nice fine crumble mix and it stops the
butter from sort of melting in that
flour so that's the basic crumble mix
but I'm not finished yet
usually 2/3 crumble 1/3 musle mix that
in if you haven't got mule then crunchy
granola works brilliantly too lovely now
start off in the center and work your
way around I want the the crispiness on
the top the puree on the bottom with a
caramel and then the texture in the
center a good
tip turn the gas back on I want it
bubbling before it goes in the oven cuz
then you just got to cook the top so as
soon as you see that caramel starting to
Bubble down the side in she goes let's
go bake at 200° C for 12 to 14 minutes
until golden brown
smells
[Music]
amazing
beautiful still
bubbling and look at it a delicious but
very simple crumble with apples at the
absolute best
[Music]
beautiful next my tricks of the trade
and kitchen
tips first up cooking pasta a great
budget basic to keep in the cupboard it
can be easily undercooked or overcooked
here's how to do it properly first water
in nice large pan to make sure the
pest's got sufficient room to cook
evenly nicely seasoned absolutely
crucial olive oil in that stops the
pasta from sticking together bring it up
to the
bow that's a rolling boil the secret
there it stops the past from sticking
together and it gently rolls it around
now this is Angel pasta nice thin pasta
takes 3 and 1 half to 4 minutes so into
the pan as it hits the water it melts
and then you turn it around tongs as
that starts to melt gently twist that
into the pan bring it back up to the
boil if you bad at timing then set a
timer beautiful to test it lift a little
Strand and you can actually feel it with
your fingers it's still nice and
firm Al Dente not a bite not a strong
bite but just just really nice and firm
inside definitely not crunchy and then
into a collander drain the
pasta in a light seasoning salt and
pepper a
tablespoon of olive oil mix that through
that stops IT from sticking together and
look there you go beautiful pasta al
dente cooked
perfectly a tip for making the most of
spare bread Blitz leftovers into
breadcrumbs great for stuffing or crab
cakes or cut into chunks and freeze for
perfect croutons on demand or simply
tear and use in a delicious rustic
salad dried pulses like chickpeas or
lentils are great for Soups and stews
and cost pennies but don't season them
until the end of the cooking or the salt
makes them go
tough for perfect boiled potatoes always
start them off in cold water and never
boiling water this way by the time the
centers of the potatoes are cooked the
ow side won't be falling apart and when
you're cooking potatoes always cook
extra so there's leftovers they're
fantastic to have on hand for making my
delicious noi and potato rusties or a
classic bubblin
squeak Follow My ultimate cookery course
packed with key
lessons top tips and 100 recipes to take
your life on and you'll literally be
cooking yourself into a better Chef many
of these amazing recipes are on my app
please check out the app store for
details go on get
cooking